now to our coronavirus coverage more
than three millions lives now taken by
the virus
globally and for context that's more
than the population of houston
for the latest tom hanson joins us in
new york
cases on the rise with several states
across the country
battling new infections the cdc blames
dangerous variants and relaxed
restrictions
including ending mass mandates for the
increase in cases
all roads to defeating the pandemic go
through the path of successfully and
quickly vaccinating the country
it's a race for shots with nearly a
third of american adults
now fully vaccinated 50 percent have
received at least one dose
we're trying to get as soon as possible
he said we want this then as soon as
possible
but with the variance infecting young
americans and more than 37 thousand
people hospitalized nationwide
experts warned the u.s strategy to
out-vaccinate a mutating virus could
derail
progress numbers are higher than they've
ever been before
in canada officials are sounding the
alarm infection rates now
outpace those in the u.s and threaten to
overrun
hospitals it's worst in the provinces of
alberta
and ontario where police now have new
powers to curb the spread
this wave is different from previous
waves in part
because the variants of concern are more
communicable
and more serious and some better news
here in new york hospitalizations in the
state have dropped to their lowest point
since december
and new york city's mayor bill de blasio
says 5 million new yorkers should be
vaccinated
by june tom hanson cbs news new york